what's the story baby nothing [ __ ]
johnny's smoothie looking good
looking good you got a new [ __ ] head
doula rule look at you they do like
every three weeks sure sure you get hair
on your neck i said i can't shave the
thing yeah i get hair everywhere you
gotta go to an old school barber with
the phone i love that he's gotta put the
[ __ ] thing on your neck and shave it
i don't know if it's a jewish thing or i
don't know but you have caveman anyone
who goes bald it's everywhere above the
top of my head how [ __ ] up looks on my
back ball that's my hair on the pillow
yeah but you're supposed to you're 50
something that's right you know what i'm
saying i'm you know but it's all my
whole family the worst is the back here
i got a thing to shave the back here
because it's [ __ ] gross dollar shave
club you got to put something together
you got to give them a call they got to
do something because
they like with the word razor when they
used to do it that it can't go all the
way down you have to stick you're going
to stick with the handle if you see that
scratching hand
you have a hand with a stick on it you
scratch your back with the stick okay i
used to have one for my [ __ ] like a
little stick and you just [ __ ]
from the back if you're a little too fat
you're mathematically inclined you can't
scratch your ass you can't wipe your
muffler it's monday [ __ ] is a
beautiful day to be alive
uh what the [ __ ] fort lauderdale was
great thank you if you uh
if you live in the fort lauderdale area
south miami whatever the [ __ ] you're
from if you came to the shows last week
i had a great time
uh i've always had this special thing
with florida the kind of sort of where i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is like when
i get there first i'm like i'm in
[ __ ] florida i'm gonna swap [ __ ]
yeah and then it just builds up and it
gets beautiful and uh i really had a
great time it's a great [ __ ] club
that hard rock casino is pretty
interesting man it's pretty interesting
that
you don't really need to go to vegas to
lose your [ __ ] mind no more the
reason why vegas is dead i thought it
was because of the economy
it's not really because of the economy
because
these different cities i don't know
which ones they exactly are like
atlantic city you know whatever uh they
have casinos and some of these casinos i
mean when i was a kid and i went to
atlanta city i'm like [ __ ] this
this does not compare with vegas this is
not i don't even know why they did this
but now
20 years later i'm starting to see it i
have a i'm very fortunate i get to go
with joe to the fights in vegas you know
once or twice a year
so i always observe you've got to
observe where you're at you see the
growth and you see if there's cranes and
you see if there's construction going on
so when i pull into like you know and
then when you go to a casino i mean
sometimes you go to casino and the
casino's job is to have everything there
you're going to need
everything they even tell you in the
[ __ ] bathroom you need anything come
down a comb a douche a [ __ ] uh tampon
whatever [ __ ] you need they'll give you
you know they have shopping whether it's
expensive or not they have shopping at
the at the casinos you know they have
fine dining and they also have pizzas
and they have food courts i don't know i
always get confused i think for the two
fights they either go at the mandalay
bay casino
or the other casino and there's one of
the casinos that has a food court so you
don't drop 80 [ __ ] dollars a meal
while you're there and you got to stand
online you can just go get a quick slice
of pizza at the food court they have a
movie theater
uh the mgm grand i think that's the okay
that's the one i get them confused so
please don't quote me on this but i went
to the hard rock last week so i'm at the
hard rock and whatever you go down the
stairs
you got the hard rock restaurant you got
a food court pizza
deli
you know cuban chinese you've got a spa
you've got a pool you've got shopping
you've got hard rock memorabilia then
you walk outside and have a complete
different world
they have more restaurants a little
fancier swankier type restaurants they
have nightlife they had bongos
that you know toy stores they had all
this [ __ ] i mean i walked around every
day
and every day i saw what they were doing
and i kept saying now i get it the
24-hour kitchen i ate that let me tell
you something it was superb for what i
was getting i was very blown away the
first time i got that i was starving i
just got two eggs and an oatmeal at 11
o'clock at night i don't know why i just
didn't feel like nothing you know if
they [ __ ] up the eggs and the oatmeal
and there's nothing reason to eat yeah
and i had it and the eggs were delicious
the oatmeal was delicious i think one of
the days i had uh
a chopped salad it was [ __ ] delicious
you know but the one day
you know let me tell you something i
live in california and sometimes i
forget i forget and i don't forget
i don't forget i always try to keep it
as old-fashioned as i could be and and i
know that for some people a lot of
people listen to podcasts
uh they're a little young and i have
different [ __ ] issues and i have if
shoes for you know i hate when i go to
buy something
at any business
and i'm saying this and i know i'm gonna
get some backlash for it from people i
hate when i go to [ __ ] buy something
and there's somebody behind the counter
who doesn't understand the language
it bothers me a little bit it pisses me
the [ __ ] off and i don't get mad at them
they just come to america they're
looking to strive i get mad at the
people that hire them
because these are the people are going
to be talking to your customers
so if people are going to come in here
that do not understand what the [ __ ]
you're talking about number two if
you're going to hire somebody make them
knowledgeable of the foods and how
they're served and how they're prepared
you know a lot of people look at
businesses as investments i talked about
this with the northridge dairy queen
i went up to me and my wife moved to the
valley four or five years ago before
mercy was even a thought and one night
we're on a date night and we go let's go
to dairy queen and we both got dairy
queen and it was [ __ ] horrific really
it was horrific and we looked at the
people who owned it and absolutely they
were from another country i'm not going
to mention i'm not going to be uh
racially here it doesn't matter my point
is that there was [ __ ] somewhere else
and they didn't know a dairy queen was
they bought a dairy queen because of an
investment
so when we went in there we were looking
for a slurpee whatever they're like we
don't know what the [ __ ] it is you know
those great mr misties with the ice
cream and it was like they didn't know
you know and i got upset and i see it
sometimes me and my wife go to get
spaghetti at this [ __ ] horrific place
and burbank
and last time we went in there i had to
say something to my wife because i'm
like i don't [ __ ] around with these
people they don't know what you're
talking about they don't know how to
serve spaghetti they're from another
[ __ ] country they don't even eat
spaghetti in their own [ __ ] culture
to serve it nobody's ever taught them
how to serve it how the [ __ ] the
presentation you know whether it has
this or not on it yeah what the [ __ ] so
you gotta tell them terry so i'm sitting
there the other day and then i'm in the
east coast now
one thing i love is old jews i love old
jews that let you know how the [ __ ] it
is because we don't have this here i do
not have this freedom and this honesty
in los angeles and anything that you do
i'm in the entertainment business so the
people i deal with can't make eye
contact they won't return your calls uh
they rather not return the call than
give you a no
that is the weirdest thing that i've
ever encountered if i go in and do
something for you instead of you going
joe you were not right for the part
they'll avoid contact they'll avoid with
everything all together
so maybe somewhere down the line they'll
bump into you with a job and you you
know it's just creepy [ __ ] creepy
[ __ ] human being [ __ ] humans don't
treat each other like this [ __ ] so
they don't look you know it's just a
it's a [ __ ] you see these people and
you know they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know in their daily lives
they're [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
but they try to keep it together those
people i spot i spot those people right
the [ __ ] off when they try to keep it
together because i know they can't keep
it together for that long eventually
their true [ __ ] colors will come out
eventually within [ __ ] minutes
they'll say something you go oh i
[ __ ] get it
so
that does not happen here we don't see
that here
we do not see people live through their
emotions here at all their emotion is
people even go to church in this town as
a social activity people will switch
religions
just to be an associate oh my god you
know
jim
norton comes to this church that's
that's the reason people are [ __ ]
disgusting out here
so you're damn in this food court in uh
in [ __ ] south florida whatever fort
lauderdale at the hard rock
and nothing looks good you know when you
walk from window to window and nothing
[ __ ] looks good i want to go to
jedelli i'm not gonna move for a [ __ ]
corned beef a pastrami sandwich i go to
the cuban spot everything didn't look
that good you know and some [ __ ]
swahilian was serving
i go to the [ __ ] chinese thing that
[ __ ] looked disgusting
and i didn't want to sit in the
restaurant again i didn't want a [ __ ]
omelet i didn't want a philly
cheesesteak i didn't want none of that
[ __ ] so i'm sitting there and i'm going
from window to window to see what could
yell out at me what screamed my name
and i look over and i see this little
jewish guy probably like lee's dad like
my age that's all that's all that
flooring all south florida is he's got
sandals on
he's got uh no yarmulke but his hairs
he doesn't have a yamacon but i could
tell when i saw him this is my man right
here this is
this is juice central
so how often does this happen that you
see some guy you're like i gotta stay
here
i just know
i just have a feeling i i i feel other
people that are like me so yeah so i'm
looking at this guy and i'm like oh
let me just see what this [ __ ]
is gonna do maybe he's gonna order
something that's interesting and he goes
excuse me
do you work hands-on he tells this kid
and i don't know what nationality this
kid is i know he's not american he's not
spanish
he's not brazilian he's something else i
don't know and
he goes to the kid excuse me do you work
here and he's kind of nice the guy he's
opening up very nice hey how are you
because you work here kid diego's listen
i need a nice sandwich all right he goes
i wanna
uh this on this
with a little bit of this and he goes on
top of that i want some liver
right just like that i want some liver i
think it goes huh
he goes i want liver liver you know
liver you got the liver it's around here
somewhere he can't find it the guy he's
like liver
liver you know living the guys like
living
living living i'm standing right there
i'm about to and the guy looks at me
like
can you believe this [ __ ]
and he looks back at the [ __ ] guy and
he goes liver liver you put on a
sandwich you know liver you don't know
what liver is and the guy's like
liver liver like you keep saying i do
not know liver you [ __ ] liver let the
guy's trying to keep it together i can
see his face getting red he's like five
foot two and he's like liver i told your
liver don't you know how to say [ __ ]
liver who hired you what the and also in
the middle of his rage goes where's your
manager maybe that [ __ ] guy speak
english and he turns and the door swings
open like you couldn't write this the
door swings open and the guy comes out
with a dot and a [ __ ] turban i mean
he looks at him he goes
liver i'm looking for [ __ ] liver
because the guy was old now he's getting
upset his liver i want liver on my
sandwich and the guy's like and he was
like you don't know either what the [ __ ]
what can somebody please hire somebody
that's a [ __ ] american and he says
something in this thing and as he pulls
away
he looks at me we make eye contact and
he goes tell me about it i said to him
tell me about it i but now finally
somebody thinks like me i go tell me
about it he goes go [ __ ] yourself too
and he just walks away from me nine out
of ten i would have told the old man to
go [ __ ] himself but i haven't been told
to go [ __ ] myself in such a long time
like that but i kind of liked it i was
like i love this [ __ ] old guy i was
like yes there's finally oh [ __ ] jews
in the world
he told me to [ __ ] off that's what he
said i go hey tell me about it you know
because he he yelled once the hindu came
out with the turban he [ __ ] lost it
he looked at him like i was looking for
an american and they throw this [ __ ]
guy out here this is worse than sprint
because sprint always throws a [ __ ]
hand away at the end
you get them call sprint bro don't throw
an american out you need to throw this
[ __ ] full court press on you don't
throw a handle at you and your world is
done
your world is done you've been little
hello what the [ __ ]
i'm telling you i did not call cambodia
uh and the thing is i i know these
people because that's all okay so for
people who don't know fort lauderdale
and boca raton that area everyone from
new york new jersey boston that's all
that is all the jews go down there when
they're about 70 60 something like that
so the the partners casino probably had
a deli in new york delegate fantastic
assassin
but that's just because that's i mean my
dad goes to win every week but they
probably didn't have they probably had
turkey and ham that's what they had they
had turkey
ham corn beef yeah no brisket no no
breast cake that's why he was mad too
and they had so and liver
is this like it's like only jews like
it's no [ __ ] sure you used to send me
to the store for tongue oh oh yeah
tongue her me and
she i said this asari next time i've
never done tongue but it's uh chop chop
liver isn't that bad it's pretty [ __ ]
strong to put on a sandwich you've had
it i've i have it occasionally you can
only really have a couple bites i
couldn't imagine smearing it on a
sandwich like cream cheese but this guy
wanted it and he was making his own
sandwich and that poor guy was like all
i know is turkey ham
roast pizza what kind of cheese you want
to put on it but then again you know i
don't know i just feel sometimes and
listen you gotta give everybody an equal
opportunity employed and i'm surprised
the guy started out nice because all the
old jews i know like that they start out
yelling like they start out already
angry he was angry but he was keeping
control i could tell he was angry when
he walked up yeah like he was looking
for something to [ __ ] with him so he
could run back to his wife and yell at
some [ __ ] at the penny slots
that's the thing about casinos and i
love gambling it's it's
it's just it's in me
but whenever i go to a casino like that
it's just like when you see like the
hordes of old people just like with that
penny slots with buckets and pennies i'm
like jesus let me tell you what i did
see this weekend it goes to show you i
saw
and i never saw them in vegas they told
me to have it in vegas i've never seen
invade you play war or oh the car game
the card game yeah you've seen that
before i don't know if i've seen in
vegas i've never seen it in vegas the
guy goes is very popular i didn't see
one person playing war all [ __ ]
weekend
but when i went and asked the guy on
saturday go so this is just like regular
one he goes yeah ten dollars a card i
was like
that's not me i'm a cuban jew i worked
too hard to [ __ ] gamble ten dollars a
card but he was very popular so i
watched the table every time i walked by
there was never no not one person i saw
playing one probably all blackjack
roulette and
i think they don't have craps they don't
have craps for roulette really in vegas
but i did see like a machine where it's
virtual blackjack a chick is in a
computer yeah yeah they'll check that
she's playing cards you can't do that
that's that's just gonna rip you off
right away but when it's a machine they
can rig it at least when it's cards you
have some sort of a chance so a couple
weeks ago right since like you said you
opened up the conversation
a lot of people moved down from the east
coast yeah to whatever when you and i
did the documentary uh we went to a
corner one day and i looked at a house
and i said to you that's the house that
started my movement
like that was the final straw in my
decision to leave i got accused of
robbing a house
uh my friend called a couple weeks ago
anthony vanery
anthony renee is running for freehold
but he's replacing thomas liggio a good
good guy tommy leggio's a good guy the
father
uh i had uh we'll get to this later uh
when i went to a couple weeks ago i got
a email a facebook from a friend of mine
a girl that
freshman year i [ __ ] went to freshman
class and she was i was friends with a
kid named michael degumi who came to the
stress factory who him and i were very
tight growing up okay
and he had a friend named rosandi
agustino and roseanne came over we were
all diaz di agustino de guomi we're all
in the same homeroom and graham in high
school
and she needed a locker and i said to
roseanne my freshman year i mean i
didn't know nobody hang on roseanne if
you want you could share lockers with me
so she shared lockers with me and it was
great i put my books on that i didn't
really then she had a friend her friend
needed a lock she was getting my maria
donna what i think that was her name
she's no longer she died in high school
like two years later
and so me and roseanne always stayed
friends to strengthen the bond roseanne
had a brother that i was very tight with
me and him took a hit of acid one time
and got on the bus in new york and took
it all the way down to the jersey shore
and played the ac dc on the [ __ ] big
one of those uh ghetto blasters and the
bus driver kept stopping going next time
you put that thing on we're gonna throw
you off the bus 10 minutes in we put
[ __ ] highway to hell on the guy would
stop the bus i had a thousand laughs
with dia christina the agostino was
crazy when i was kids
so i got a call i got an email from her
on facebook a couple weeks ago saying
hey i see that you're coming forth live
there
i'm gonna come see you i'm gonna tell
the girls and i didn't know what she was
talking about and she said these two
names uh
and there were two girls i hung out with
one of them i had a an encounter with i
was romantically with her for a while we
were kids and the other one i was just
dear friends with and we all grew up
together we were all in this circle
later on they came into my life from 16
to
22 or something like that we were always
together and then uh
in the winter of 84 i was [ __ ] up guys
i was just in bad shape i i broke away
from society like in june
i was in love with a girl and we were
dating and then we broke up and she
started dating her old boyfriend and i
was looking for the girl to save me
sometimes you're not looking for a
relationship you're looking for a woman
to save me this was my ticket into you
know having a house and all this [ __ ]
and in the back of my mind i thought if
i hooked up with her you know so
whatever happened so i want to and then
cocaine was pretty relevant and relevant
it was everywhere so i got hooked on the
cocaine i was trying to get a job hold
the job in new york and it was just
falling apart i couldn't make it to my
job at five o'clock you know somebody
said that i did the eddie bravo podcast
last night and people were hitting lee
like how's he gonna wake up in the
morning [ __ ] if i pay i'm gonna be
there i'm gonna be there in the morning
especially especially for you
[ __ ] but in these days i didn't
think that way
i didn't give a [ __ ] about anybody or
their time schedule or what it meant you
know
i had no responsibility i didn't claim
any and uh in that process they hung out
with this other girl named joy and
liggio that was a very sweet girl
and i became friendly with her and the
mother to the brothers and one day i
went to cali after i screwed my uncle
over the one that did the podcast yeah
after i tried to rob him at gunpoint
when i got off the plane
i got a call i called somebody and they
go hey uh
joanne's looking for you sometimes i
call joanne and she goes my mom said if
you ever need a place to sleep you could
sleep here so i immediately went over
there god forbid i wouldn't pass up an
opportunity to sleep in somebody's house
for free and mooch their [ __ ] food in
those days you know so i would cover
that [ __ ] i would just have the money to
snort god forbid
so i stayed with them i think i i moved
in with them uh october like the end of
october or on halloween
and i stayed with them until like the
first week of december and i got to tell
you people was it was eight six weeks i
didn't i didn't make any effort to
change my life you know sometimes
somebody puts you on the couch and they
say joey this is you open the
refrigerator to all you all i want from
you is to wash your dishes and do me a
favor bro get up in the morning go get a
job go get a job to help yourself out so
in six to eight weeks you get an
apartment here you can stay here for
free i'm not gonna charge you that
you've done it with people you can stay
here for free i don't want nothing from
you all i want you to do is wake up at a
keep this clean
i don't want no [ __ ] you know don't
don't put drama in my life but most
important if i'm going to give you this
opportunity two or three months to live
rent free
get a job
you think i got a job [ __ ] no i wanted
to be johnny coke dealer i wanted to be
johnny coke dealer and johnny mafioso
and
sell coke and burn people
so one day
one day like a december 12th
i never forget the date
she comes to me and she goes you got to
go just out of the blue
she gets i'm throwing you out you
haven't made any effort to [ __ ] do
anything with your life and you haven't
stopped snorting coke
and it was true i'm not i'm not here to
tell nobody i wasn't
and i took my little army bag in those
days i had an army bag filled with
clothes and a couple pictures and i
[ __ ] just lived on the streets that
was when the last three weeks of
december when i basically just lived on
the streets now you talk about the east
coast being cold i lived on the streets
i took my luggage to a friend's house
and i would pick through clothes at
night and change and take a shower
wherever i could and it was just a
horrible living it was a horrible way of
living so i hit rock bottom december
31st 1984 i robbed this kid joelle i
went to a hotel and it snowed a lot it
snowed like two feet of snow and i knew
they were going to come get me i had
like 2 000 of that money and i called my
teacher mr terenova that's called the
podcast and he picked me up and i left
that area forever and that was it i got
my i went up to mr t tried to i stayed
clean
and about three weeks in
i get a call i call a friend of mine
they're like dog what the [ __ ] did you
do
i'm like what are you talking about and
they go
the cops aren't looking for you but
somebody robbed legion's house
and they know it's you man and i go dog
are you [ __ ] kidding me i haven't
even
at that time when the legal house had
been robbed
i wasn't i was never even in that area i
owe 20 000 my step my godfather was
looking to kill me my stepfather wasn't
going to kill me
god knows who else was looking to
[ __ ] put a bullet in my [ __ ] leg
trust me i wasn't going to go back to
west new york with bergen whole book
none of those [ __ ] spots
so
he tells me this and he's like bro you
robbed the house and i [ __ ] called
another friend of mine and they're like
yeah
we got the call last night
when they were at the football dinner
somebody broke into the house and took
all the jewelry and [ __ ]
now
the the other part of this story was
that johan liggio's mother
was a degenerate card gambler
and i knew because i knew people in
hoboken i knew different
money and she had been people money from
her daughter's college fund
i knew all these things that i only i
knew him you know the daughter didn't
know
the husband didn't know this was before
he became freeholder this was when he
was down and out he had lost his job at
pepsi
so uh
i get this call you know you robbed the
house and i'm like i didn't run no
[ __ ] house you know
but it didn't matter
listen i had everything against me i had
no
real alibi you know t was like he's here
with me so what did i do i called the
chief of police in northberg who i knew
dearly i hung out with his son
and i said mr b you know i've known you
a long time i've eaten at your house
listen
i've done a lot of bad things i robbed
this i did this you know that he laughed
i go but this thing i didn't do if you
want me to come down and give a
statement or get fingerprinted or
whatever
and he goes listen something ain't right
but i'll get back to you later
so
uh i guess that they broke in but there
was no real breaking there was no that's
why she thought it was me because there
was no there was a key uh i never really
had a key to the [ __ ] house i just
knocked and they let me in and i had the
back door was open because the two
so they accused me of robbing the
[ __ ] house so this is all over the
place now and i'm trying to fight back
i'm trying to call everybody now why for
someone who's done all that stuff why
did that bother you so much
it bothered me because
i didn't rob it
at that time everything that got robbed
was me
every time and then a week later they go
oh no it was the sister and i get
[ __ ] you know somebody robbed
somebody and then i would get a call hey
bro do you hear what happened downtown
they broke into whatever's house and
then a week later it was the three
puerto ricans down the corner so i would
always get vint vintage size whatever
okay vindicator so
so even though you were doing it when
you didn't do you're like it wasn't me
it was yeah there was a point where
everything that somebody did it went
back to me if i was even in that [ __ ]
area
and sometimes i was responsible for it
yeah and sometimes i wasn't
for some reason guys this one really
bothered me
this was at the tail end of a part of my
life when i was in bad shape
and uh when she threw me out it hurt me
because that
friend i know a lot of [ __ ] about the
mother like i'm telling you right now
i knew a lot of [ __ ] about the mother
and i thought we were good friends and i
and i understood her throwing me out of
the house hey
that i wasn't mad about that at all
this went on and it ate away at me it
ate away at me that she thought i robbed
the house you know and i knew the truth
i knew that it was an insurance camp for
her to get the cash back and uh i knew a
lot of little things you know she had
pawned the jury she was getting her
jewelry estimated
so i knew something was in the horizon
you know and uh
i got to tell you it really bothered me
but it made me who i am today
so
this went on this rumor went on and i
called one of the girls not roseanne the
agostino this is 85. i called one of the
girls and her and i remained friends
for a while even though she was tight
with joanne liggio okay this girl tasia
and i remained
for a while and then tasia got into her
own hassles her and her boyfriend killed
the couple driving it was [ __ ] crazy
it was dry they with drunk taser got
vindicated but the boyfriend ended up
going to jail
and i left
i left no right before i didn't leave
yet and her and i were very tight this
girl tasia but as time went on our
relationship and it was because of
jo-ann thing now the other girl who i
was romantically at one time with lisa i
called her one day me and my buddy were
thinking of taking a vacation called her
one day and i go hey me and my buddy
they're gonna take a vacation i want you
to sell me the package
and she put me on hold and then she
picked up the phone she goes listen i
gotta tell you something i really don't
want to do this for you
i really don't even want to talk to you
again i can't believe you robbed
joanne's house because this is the last
conversation we'll ever have and that
really destroyed me
because we weren't romantically involved
then but i considered her a friend but
not in a way not really you know i knew
i knew what it was i knew what time it
was so eventually within time they both
stopped talking to me and that really
bothered me and today i could look in
the eye i mean we've discussed a lot of
things on this podcast i didn't rob that
[ __ ] house i i wasn't it wasn't even
in my realm at that time i was trying to
get out i was trying to really like
that's it i had gotten away with murder
yeah so why would i want to [ __ ] go
back you know
so when roseanne hit me up a few weeks
ago she told me she goes i'm going to
come to your show my husband go no
problem i go but listen
i'm dirty you know i just guys want you
to know i know the style of connor you
like because she always posts what
comedians she goes to see okay so on
when i was down this weekend i didn't
even think about it but when i hit her
back with the message she hit me back
that she was gonna invite those two
girls okay those two girls all live in
the same neighborhood with other people
from my hometown wow
so uh
i told her and i never heard back from
her you know she probably went to those
two girls and said he's coming and they
go are you [ __ ] kidding me don't you
remember what he did
did it bother me bro uh
a little bit it bothered me it did if
you don't about me it really didn't
bother me but it just struck me wild
that i had the relationship i had with
this girl even if
she went to them and they told her that
i thought that this girl would at least
go you know what you guys don't want to
go let me go me and him had a friendship
at one time but i guess uh like i said
the other girl that had the locker died
in a car accident i mean we all went to
the wake and i was very tight
so it just goes to show you that uh so
it never came out that it was the mom
doing it never came out i never really
wanted to attack it at that point you
know i was living this happening of 85.
i left new jersey in june of 85. but
that time she had gotten a check
then i bumped into her one day in 93 i
went home
i bumped into a political function but
the people i was with were throwing heat
she couldn't say nothing to me yeah they
looked at me they gave me dirty looks
but there was nothing i gave them daily
looks back at that time i didn't give a
[ __ ] but i would have gone up there
looked her in the face and said i know
what you did
it wasn't me i know what you did and i'm
not mad at you
you know if i would have robbed the
[ __ ] house i would have got arrested
for it yeah if it would have really been
me if they would have witnesses and
proof and i would have sold the jewelry
where did jewelry go you know what i'm
saying and those days you could track
jewelry still you could track it where'd
the jewelry go as soon as they put an
alert out the fence or the cops send
[ __ ] paperwork to all those they fax
paperwork to all those jewelry stores
that they're looking for fifty thousand
worth of jewelry like they said they
robbed yeah she said she had like fifty
thousand with the jewelry which she
really had she probably did have
so but that really but that
pain that that brought me fueled me
it fueled me and if we remember when we
shot the documentary we shot it i had
that piece in there yeah i never had it
because i didn't want it to i didn't
want to make the documentary negative i
didn't
at first when i had the plans to shoot
the documentary our plans were to take
you to the places i robbed and stuff i
didn't want to show you the bad things i
want to show you the good things and
that's why i did that i had that piece
in there remember you shot me you shot
it right in front of the house this is
the house i got accused of robbing blah
blah blah
but today i really don't give a [ __ ]
about them you know i feel bad that we
don't talk
i feel bad that they fed me at one time
and i don't have a relationship with
them i'm sure they see the articles they
put my hometown paper about me and i
don't know how they feel or whatever but
i really don't give a [ __ ] my that made
me that gave me the fuel that accused
to be honest with you you know it's like
having a jar of mayonnaise and you're
trying to open it mm-hmm and you can't
open it and you're working it for an
hour and your grandmother comes in who's
got arthritis in her fingers and she
goes and she cracks the [ __ ] can yeah
that
situation
was
the the catalyst it was responsible
for setting me out in the world yeah
because that's what made me want to
prove that i wasn't that person
so i i keep that theft close to my heart
that accusation because
it fueled my rage oh yeah man i feel my
fire it really fueled who the [ __ ] i was
because i didn't care about i robbed a
lot of [ __ ] i'm not here to tell you i
did not rob [ __ ] i was a petty [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] thief but that i didn't
rob i had a little bit more class than
to rob somebody who had helped me at
that time you know they weren't involved
with drugs they weren't heavies they
didn't do nothing like that so they were
out of my reign
yeah you know all those people that
helped me were safe
you know that's why the people you know
lubes and ascalis's and the valenos
those people were my brothers they stuck
with me through thick and thin in those
days i'm an animal today if you don't
stick with me through thick and thin
i don't want you around you know it was
interesting because i worked with two
comedians
in that in uh
in
fort lauderdale this week
one of the guys
i knew from l.a and you know when i used
to
do the podcast with felicia she used to
have this [ __ ] friend this uh
this jeff uh
i don't know what his [ __ ] name was
uh
he he books montreal or some [ __ ] now
you know he he books montreal jeff i
don't know what his [ __ ] name is
and it's funny because this kid said to
me he goes you know joey man i'm
watching on stage and everything's
working out and
he goes years ago [ __ ] you had a lot of
people that
would really down on you and he goes
this guy
especially and i i remember him he was
at felicia's one guy
and i shook his hand but i knew that
first off the guy's a gay guy that he
needs a push
you know those guys that are [ __ ]
flaming inside but they just need to
they need a guy to grab him by the neck
and go tonight you're going to suck my
[ __ ]
i'm going to set you i'm going to
crumble what's that word when you
break a woman out when it was a pimp say
i i busted her out and [ __ ] like i
turned her out oh yeah that's what
that's what he needs a guy to turn him
out okay
and uh it's funny he booked i forget
jeff whatever i think stanhope had a
problem with him too because the guy
used to charge classes to teach stand up
and stand hope went after him
and it's funny that this kid came up to
me he goes you know who really
used to every time i'd see him he'd say
stay away from diaz he's he's trouble
he's no good you know and uh
type of [ __ ] like that bothers me a
little bit yeah because these are the
people that talk to the mainstream
people i know that that half of these
[ __ ] morons are a bunch of you know
they don't like dealing with me half of
them because i tell them the truth
you know i tell them how i feel and then
that's not what they want to hear they
want you oh my god it's such a pleasure
to be no it's not a pleasure because i
know you don't give a [ __ ] about me you
have to do this because you have to do
this [ __ ]
but it's so funny how these people it's
tough to live your life you know and you
make your own bed man i made my own
[ __ ] bed i'm not here tapping out or
crying or you know i got a bunch of
[ __ ] things this week from people you
know things ain't going my way then you
got to work a little [ __ ] harder bye
guys you got to go it up go that
[ __ ] up on a monday go it up and
go for it you know but i've done a lot
of things but one of my goal was one of
my goals was always to
listen you're not going to overcome
you're not going to
change people's minds
you're never going to once a person has
a perception of you or whatever you're
not going to change their mind
the only thing you could do is keep
pushing forward
and eventually even if they don't like
you they'll look at you and go
that [ __ ] is a savage
you know maybe i don't like this but his
character is spot on
all i always wanted to be i always knew
to redeem myself and what i had done all
those years my character was in i always
had character i always had [ __ ]
character if not i would have robbed him
mm-hmm i always had character if not i
would have rob them right there at
[ __ ] gunpoint
but uh that's what i always strive for
to build my character so like that
somebody could say and i don't have
these people don't [ __ ] like me these
comic people they don't want i really
don't give a [ __ ]
that's the reason why i'm here when i
walk in the room i walk in the room i
[ __ ] in my [ __ ] hand i don't give a
[ __ ] i'm not scared of none of these
and that's why you know this podcast is
hahahi sometimes but on [ __ ] monday
mornings i come in here fueled up and
it's just to let you know that you know
what man who gives a [ __ ] somebody this
morning hit me up i don't want to go to
my job or i don't like it should i quit
and i go you can't quit your [ __ ] job
but you know what go ahead and give it a
shot if somebody don't like you having a
problem with your boss go and then let
them know you're [ __ ] better than
they are that's the only way they're
going to give you the [ __ ] props and
even if they don't like i don't give a
[ __ ] i want to go to your house to watch
tv i don't want to go eat with you to
hang out with you [ __ ] you but you will
[ __ ] respect me you will [ __ ]
respect what i do and you will respect
how i [ __ ] compose myself and how i
handle myself and that's all you want
from people i don't give a [ __ ] i don't
want no thank yous and no hugs nothing i
just want people to know this guy's a
hard worker he works hard he does what
he says he's going to do
and he [ __ ] comes through and that's
the most important thing well did you
hear what happened it's interesting you
brought this up do you hear what
happened in football this weekend no so
uh the philadelphia eagles released a
wide receiver named deshawn
so then there was
released him
right like the day an article came out
saying that he he hangs out with gang
members he grew up in compton
what he's saying is what all the police
have come out and said is when you when
you live in a place like that you're
going to grow up and you're going to
know people who end up like that so they
released him
he didn't do anything it's not like
aaron hernandez who killed somebody
they released him and they said he had
some uh some issues uh some he didn't
get along with the coaches or whatever
but they released him before he did
anything and he went out saying i'm not
a bad person
and it's a like
it's kind of like we you went through a
little bit like how what what can you
what would that feel like like if if
like a comedy club or your agent now is
like
he he hangs out with bad people or he
did this in his past and then it kind of
affects you it's kind of like what
happened to that ufc fighter a little
bit but he did something so
it hurts it hurts i'm not gonna lie it
hurts
for a minute
it hurts for a level it hurts
as you let it hurt
okay people always remember that this
shit's gonna hurt for as long as you had
let it hurt you a situation affects you
it's gonna affect you for as long
as you let it affect you listen to my
[ __ ] words because i live with this
every [ __ ] year
every [ __ ] day whether with spanish
when i first moved to north bergen
in every level you know my insecurities
weren't [ __ ] uh man-made i'm not a
guy who's gonna tell you that i hadn't
had opportunities because i'm spanish
that's [ __ ] i've never even looked
at that i've never even kind of got
categorized myself as that i categorize
myself as a [ __ ] man i know i gotta
go out there and get something every day
but when you hear something negative
about yourself or something that
somebody's taken out of perspective or
something that somebody has made a bad
call on you it hurts
if you let it for a minute then you sit
there you reflect you grab your [ __ ] and
you go you know what [ __ ] this [ __ ]
this is the gasoline that goes in my
[ __ ] tank yeah
how i look at it when somebody says
something like so i told you one day
nine out of ten most people go up to
people go hey i heard you said that i
don't say nothing because if somebody's
going to say something like that about
you knowing the efforts that you do
they're saying it from an insecure place
or they're jealous or they don't
understand i don't even like that word
jealous but they don't like it or
whatever you don't want
if they're that weak they know you're
going to [ __ ] them up mm-hmm that you
know i mean in my world when i get that
[ __ ] it hurts for 10 seconds and if i
didn't tell you i'm lying to you it
hurts it hurts for a minute it might
hurt for a day it might hurt but then
something takes over you goes you know
what
i'll take that person and then wipe my
[ __ ] ass with them it's [ __ ] in my
ass you know you take that first [ __ ]
now you take that toilet paper and wipe
your [ __ ] ass that's what i'll do
with that [ __ ] head as their tongue
is scraping my [ __ ]
and they taste the [ __ ] from my [ __ ]
ass that's how you have to think about
those [ __ ] people and you don't say
nothing to them
you don't ass you don't even give them
the time of day you let them living
their life you let them live their life
like if they know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about and meanwhile you're
digging you're digging you're moving
[ __ ] street because listen bro it's
like the [ __ ] man setting off in uh
an apocalypse now i'm in this [ __ ]
hotel hanging here and charlie's in a
bush getting [ __ ] stronger i've
always been charlie in the bush getting
[ __ ] stronger so you could sit there
with your little [ __ ] gentile buddies
and alive and hang out at the improv and
try to be cool and put whoever the [ __ ]
you want down but meanwhile [ __ ]
uncle joey aka charlie that [ __ ] is in
the bush [ __ ] with a gun and a
[ __ ] scope and a [ __ ] a bag full
of [ __ ] bullets i want to be around
this monday
march [ __ ] 30th the day the devil was
buried at sea anybody say something
about you don't feel good [ __ ] him it
only hurts for a [ __ ] minute and then
you tell him suck my dick [ __ ] out of
respect tony bennett on a [ __ ] monday
[ __ ]
pick up those [ __ ] pieces who
gives a [ __ ]
somebody
that misery loves company
so it's crazy i didn't even feel the
earthquakes this weekend
i don't know what it was but [ __ ] you
were [ __ ] no i wasn't you were eating
that ass like a [ __ ] mexican soldier
beforehand yeah but
uh okay i didn't bring in the corn i'll
bring in the corn tomorrow um
what made you think of the coin
no good no because you said mexican um
we were before but uh no not not during
we didn't we didn't feel either one and
i called terry because i knew you were
in florida i was like [ __ ] yeah people
called me right away and said call home
that there was an earthquake so
that's the type of people i'm [ __ ]
involved with you want me to tell you
why i feel good today why because i took
that on at 180. okay that one i take
that [ __ ] before and after the [ __ ]
plane man they sent me a big box of it
and i'll tell you what i'm tired you
know i'm a little tired today i'm going
to take it easy i don't have a big day
mm-hmm so i don't know how to go to 11
to 12 i thought i had to go to the
library with my daughter they do like a
read story time i was gonna go down
there and see
torture some [ __ ] read some
books and [ __ ]
they they had that they had an
elementary school like you could come in
the parents would read a book and my dad
did it once and he took it really
serious because he was on the radio so
he said with his big radio voice second
i can definitely see going to
kindergarten reading some stories with
some kids
it's a mommy and me group on mondays and
wednesdays but it's not in uh it's not
for the next two weeks so it's on
wednesday so okay that's why i was gonna
do the podcast monday and wednesday at
11
but i got to go to storybook [ __ ]
reading times
what the [ __ ] it is
but that's that's why i felt good i
could tell that uh i never used to take
i never take alpha brain before i go on
a plane ride but the 180 i take a little
thing right there right on the plane so
it's like another guy goes you want
water boom i open up the package dump it
in there
drink it and then when the plane lands i
do another one and i'm [ __ ] good like
i never really have jet lag yesterday i
slept for two hours but it wasn't it was
because i was tired you know i went to
bed [ __ ] two and got up at five so
and you went through a period a few
months ago where you're getting a lot of
ear things and you're getting sick for a
while so you might like you've been
taking that for like on the plane
because yeah because you've been like
what six seven weeks in a row now or
closer oh no i don't [ __ ] around but it
was it was very weird i'm taking a lot
better care i know how to do the road
down a lot better so
uh there's little precautions you take
the immune systems i take the strong
uh
the other one not the sport but i take
the yellow one
immune
so you know you get on a plane six seven
hours you gotta have you gotta protect
yourself i heard they make this i was
talking a buddy of mine from australia
last night he says they make this thing
that you buy at the airport and you
drink it every hour or something like
that for your body it puts a lot of
vitamins in your body you know when you
fly there's radiation on planes there's
so many [ __ ] things on the planet and
i fly twice a week so you have to take a
little [ __ ] carry yourself people and
that's why
that's the word of the day take care of
yourself it only hurts as long as you
let it [ __ ] hurt yeah it's crazy
because like
and i would love the patriots to grab
them but they won't do it because of
aaron hernandez and at first when they
brought it up i'm like yeah i guess you
i can see like after what happened you
would let him go
just so he if anything happened
but like like the article it's kind of
where it's kind of why newspapers are
going down the article didn't have any
proof it just said he hangs out with
people who are in that but
it's like that that shouldn't be illegal
that shouldn't be a reason for you to
lose your job and
it's uh mark cuban the owner of the
mavericks he came out a week or two ago
and he said that uh in like 10 years the
nfl is going to go downhill because they
they they're doing a whole nother night
of football now it's like wednesday
nights two and and then more more games
on thursdays and you know it might be it
might be [ __ ] true he said that like
when people get too greedy
people like things bad things happen
so it's kind of interesting so they're
going to start wednesday night football
i don't know but wednesday they
definitely added more thursday night
games and like now cbs is kind of
covering them and pretty soon it's gonna
be every night of the week i think i
think it's on wednesday night again now
this kid that got this sean jackson he
was he a rookie last year no he was like
four years in he had his best year last
year okay so after his best year
so they they cut him or they released
him because
of he doesn't get along with the coaches
maybe he has a chip on his shoulder yeah
but because he has gang acquaintances
well he's from south west yeah he's from
compton he it's not that he's in a gang
it's that his friends who we grew up
with and and i wouldn't have even
realized it but when i go down to drop
haul off
in those neighborhoods there's [ __ ]
gangs and it's just
a half part some of the people who live
there are very nice old people and
some of the people are gangs and it's
just when you grow up in those areas
you're gonna have friends you go to
school with that are in the gangs that's
what they said and
it's uh
listen when i went back to [ __ ] the
stress factory i realized uh
i had some friends that were heavy duty
myself yeah that over the years they
they've you know i've just this week in
uh in florida some guy came up to me and
he goes i'm your friend's partner in the
book business jesus you know a kid i
grew up with and i knew he had a partner
the guy goes my name is this and i'm his
partner i've been with him for 20 years
now and
he couldn't come but he sends his love
i'm down here so you know when i went to
the stress factory
i saw a couple [ __ ] i've been
in high school with that now you know
back then they were doing little things
but now
and a couple of them told me man they
were like bro we got you back you need
anything you want to perform here you
want to do this we could take care of
yourself yeah i took their cards and
their phone numbers and uh
this is who i grew up with this is who
the [ __ ] i am you're not gonna abandon
them no i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
abandon them they never abandoned me
yeah one guy i saw that i did a thousand
things with and i always knew where he
was that's why i did the things with him
because i knew i would never get in
[ __ ] trouble so we gotta call him
here all right
it's my little brother john evan
how's it going good man i'm happy you
woke up to do this for us again uh john
evan on the line
uh my one of my [ __ ] coaches who i
love dealing with jiu jitsu [ __ ]
savage
he has a youtube page and he has a
breakdown page and uh
we're gonna talk about eddie broadway
how you doing today mr evan
oh doing well doing well this uh
you guys get up early for this show huh
yeah we got up early man we want to get
to you first we want your information
out there
first john evan what i'm saying
that's great it's a good way to wake up
nah i woke up i went to bed at like 12.
so i was tired when i woke up at 4 30.
but you got to do what you got to do
john evan [ __ ] it
no for sure you know people people you
know i i get emails every week and some
weeks i get emails from people that
you know things aren't going well for
them they've been do and i ask them you
know do you get up early do you try a
little harder do you and this is it this
is
you get up a little early some days
you're right you know and the whole
day's in front of you so
yeah that's it john that was great john
evan i'm watching these uh these fights
the other night and i i thought about
you the whole night when i was watching
metamoris 3. i i felt like you were
right next to me you know and because
you've taught me some stuff and i didn't
uh know a lot of the high-level stuff i
was seeing watching
but uh that's why i have you on play to
break it down and we'll break down
eddie's because that was the main one
people are still talking about today a
couple weeks ago you and i were doing
something you were teaching me a few
moves
and you mentioned to me something that
kenny florian mentioned the other day
because you know and he's known for his
rubber guard and this and this but his
real world is his grappling and his side
control
yeah and
his uh
and his half guard too right the half
guard i'm sorry not side control his
half guard and uh we saw it the other
night
break it down for me john evans
yeah uh i mean
if any of you haven't seen that
metamorph event i highly recommend you
watch it um
i mean
it's it's just not often you get to see
high-level grappling
put on
into such a nice production like a
you know typical you can go to the
worlds
and if you're there in person it's
really something to see a lot of the
people come up from brazil some of them
chanted each other and it's crazy but if
you're there live you're not going to
see it with any kind of commentary
uh if you watch the live stream you can
see some commentary and that's uh it
helps a lot it helps give context but
and unless you do the sport
um the commentary has to be really good
to give it context because otherwise i
think
i think that's the problem with
jiu-jitsu with sport jiu-jitsu
it's
it's really hard to convey what's going
on in the match unless you've seen it
before because there's no way that you
can tell
uh for instance pressure like there's no
way the camera can show that
so uh you know maybe you've got two
humongous guys like say like i don't
know somebody as big as uh verdum who's
gonna be fighting
for the uh in the ufc hopefully for the
ufc heavyweight title pretty soon he
trains at my gym sometimes under my
coach cabrini and he's a humongous
person just very big and once you're
that big
if you put a shoulder on someone's face
and and have a really strong cross face
on them that can be so much pressure it
feels like your head's going to pop off
but on camera there's no way to tell
that
so
you really need good commentary to give
it contacts then
the last couple of metamorses i didn't
think really had that so great but uh
this time they had kenny florian
who commentates for ufc so he's an old
hat at it and then he also had jeff
glover who is one of the best american
grapplers and just an all-around good
guy too so um the two of them really i
think helped brought that across to the
audience so you didn't have to be
such a jiu-jitsu nerd you can be kind of
more of a casual viewer and still see
what was going on but uh the match was
fantastic
um i mean this one is it's a it's a
rematch they fought once before i think
in like 2003
was it three i think yeah
yep it was an adcc so it was nogi and
that was the big
deal about this fight hoyler
was if you don't know who he was
he is uh one of the gracies
he was named i think by gracie mag
which is a
huge jiu jitsu publication it's been
around for a long time he was named as
the
best grappler of the 90s
i think buy
his peers and just buy the magazine
maybe
they took a vote and he was the one best
grappler of the 90s so
a big deal and he's he's a smaller guy
too you know one of the much smaller
weight classes
but known also for his passing which
typically
you don't see that at the smaller weight
classes a lot of people play guard more
so they're on bottom more
but he has very good
also a very good guard but very good
passing too especially for the weight
class
a really technical good athlete on top
of it and he went into adcc where he was
fighting nogi
and uh eddie bravo caught him in a
triangle and beat him and a lot of
people said oh it was a fluke
you know like it's not going to happen
again
i don't think either of them competed
after that i might be wrong but i'm
pretty sure that neither of them ever
competed again after that so
a lot of things left to speculation
people saying that
eddie was making his career out of this
one fight he just got lucky and
all of this and you know it was really
uh
it was an interesting match to make and
everybody wanted to see them rematch but
they never did and now years and years
and years later
they finally did and it was a fantastic
match
really
really
good unfortunately
spoiler alert if you haven't seen it yet
it went the distance
so because it's supposed to be
submission only but there was a 20
minute time limit
so
you know still you can argue it either
way but
i mean i think most people that were
there even to the casual fan they could
see that uh
i mean one way if you're not sure who's
winning in the grappling match you can
look at who's defending more and who's
attacking more
and
hoiler was on top for a lot of the fight
i think for the whole first five minutes
he was on top and good passing position
trying to get a knee through the pass
knee through the middle pass to work but
not able to get it to work
and then eddie
was able to utilize his lockdown and for
me that was the
that was kind of like
the most surprising and in a way the
saddest part of it too because
uh the lockdown is not just eddie's
moves the eddie kind of popularized it
but it's a common jiu-jitsu move and
hoiler seemed to have no answer for it
he didn't know
how to get out of it he wasn't doing the
right stuff he was
straightening his leg most of the time
which is the opposite of what you want
to do
and he looked a little lost and because
of that he got swept a few times he
slept back and he stayed on top
but
in the end he got put into
a couple of different compromising
positions where he was nearly a calf
crusher and then also nearly in a neck
crank and he was uh
in danger of being put into a twister
which is also in that crank and
you know if if you have to look at it
that way he was defending he he was
never putting any in danger of being
submitted so
i would definitely have to give this
fight to eddie and i'm not biased either
way i really have no affiliation with
either of those two camps so
um
it was just it was a good fight and i
would have loved to seen it with no time
limit for sure
just just go until somebody passes out
yeah i think so you know even though
you could argue that that favors hoiler
because he seemed to be
the better athlete of out of the two
even though eddie was still pushing
pretty strong towards the end
um
that's the only way to leave it
to to get a definitive answer and
submission only the only problem with
submission only is that
when you do it with no time limits
most matches sure they're going to end
in five minutes they're going in 10
maybe 20
sometimes 30 but every once in a while
you'll get that match that goes like an
hour and a half long and it's just
unwatchable for the casual spectator and
even for the hardcore spectator if it's
uh especially if it's more of a stalling
game it's like an hour and a half you
just it's hard to make time in your day
for that and especially if there's like
five more matches
um and how do you schedule that too if
you're an event organizer so that's kind
of the conundrum with sport jiu jitsu
right now
these rules are in my opinion much
better than rules for say like the ibjjf
of the worlds where they give you points
for sweeping
takedowns
um you know passing guard all of that
it doesn't matter there's
there's no point no points
just you submit or you don't
so that way it becomes much more pure
jiu-jitsu i believe but uh also then you
run into that no time limit issue so
it can be hard to run a tournament that
way
i uh
really saw one other thing that night
that i think a lot of people saw unless
you're crazy
there's something there i could watch
one of these once a
month i would i would pay to see these
live
i would go down i would have paid 100
bucks to go down there that night
i think they're very interesting john
evan i think they're a little more like
the way they did this show
compared to like a tournament that i've
been to like the time i only been to one
with you at gmac that day
vmac gmack
but uh i liked how they did it i could
see this on pay-per-view once a month
i think that there's a market you know
what you so what you got kicked out of
the ufc you're a [ __ ] black belt in
jiu jitsu why just open up a school
you know you could jujitsu wise to your
[ __ ] 60.
you know that right john evan especially
if you've been doing it for 20 years at
40 years
absolutely that's the beauty of jiu
jitsu and
you know that's
i mean you could see that here and
people wanted to see people paid money
and it was a main event to see these two
guys that were nearly 40 right uh i
think coilers
are 48. and eddie's 43. that's that's
really yeah right exactly
nearly nearly 50 right
48 years
old and you know they're not like these
are not athletes in their prime
and watching these two guys and first of
all too
what amazing athletes is for being
well into their 40s you know especially
for hoiler and being able to go 20
minutes
in in a match which are being
videotaped and both of the you can't
imagine the pressure on these guys like
if you've never competed before
and uh
you know
it's a completely different thing but
also when you get to that level
eddie bravo owns that the tenth planet
system like if you see a tenth planet
out there it's associated with eddie
bravo a lot of pro fighters in the usc
come to him you know hoyler gracie being
named
he's a gracie for one so it's a lot of
pressure right there like you can't be a
gracie and be bad at jiu jitsu it's uh
he was just not accepted
and also being named the best fighter of
the 90s he's a legend he's the son of
helio gracie and just
it goes on and on so much pressure and
you have all these students and everyone
that looks up to you and you get out
there and you haven't competed in 10
years
and uh you know you have an adrenaline
dump and you still
not being athletes in the prima they
went out there and they put it on on the
line and they just really went for it
over 20 minutes and had an amazing
feeling i thought it was awesome and
that's
so hard to do for you know the average
20 year old would have a really hard
time with that but they
pushed the pace the whole time it was an
exciting fight which is more than even
safe for a lot of fights
and uh man i don't know i thought it was
great i uh
like i said you know
you've been teaching me for the last
nine months and
i watched some stuff that night that was
just amazing i had never even seen
before i don't know what they were doing
you know uh one thing i learned from you
is patience john evan a couple weeks ago
we were messing around and i said to you
you want to teach me a north south choke
and i'm [ __ ] 300 pounds
and you're barely 160 and i laid on top
and i could hear your [ __ ] ribs
crushing but you're like no no you're
okay and i'm like what i love this guy
and
you [ __ ]
you know you had patience
you're like okay he's 300 pounds there's
nothing i can do about that all i could
do is keep my composure breathe and i'm
gonna get out of this
and you [ __ ] did this little
shrimping [ __ ] and next thing you know
you were out of it you know how long it
took eddie to get that
locked down last night
it was a while before you could get in
five [ __ ] minutes to get the lock
down yeah last night so he he first got
the one hook he said
the black mamba and then he went
for the lockdown
and he goes it took him five minutes to
get it that's patience
and then he spoke about the electric
chair how he he works on that a lot
but he goes you know what uh he was
surprised that
hoyler wasn't prepared for the electric
chair
whatever they call that [ __ ]
but he said even then like he goes i was
he goes it's a move that you have to you
know it steps
he goes it steps and and there's one
point where jack what was the name not
kenny florian
but the other guy was jeff however jeff
glover said that
eddie wasn't known for his cardio but he
was very technical where hoyler was more
of an athlete
yes that's true
yeah it um you know
that fight it was crazy uh
spoiler was in a very good knee through
the middle passing position um and the
part for me that was a little bit sad
was either
either hoiler has not updated his game
enough since maybe he was last competing
which has been a while
or
he just didn't give eddie the respect
that he deserved and didn't study up on
him because
that lockdown is pretty common and
anyone that knows
eddie and knows anything about his game
like
it's pretty common knowledge that he
uses the lockdown a lot and especially
from half guard
also i mean heavy just jumped right into
half guard from the get-go
but uh
hoiler i would have loved to have seen
him trying to avoid that a little bit i
mean there's there's a couple things you
don't do in life you know you don't
tug on superman's cape you don't spit in
the wind you don't fight in eddie
bravo's half guard you just don't do it
not a good idea
and he just allowed him to go right
there and i think maybe he wanted to
beat him at his game but
why you know i mean clearly did not work
out and especially if you're gonna fight
there
why allow him to get the lock down well
and and why not know how to get out of
it he he wasn't doing any of the right
stuff he allowed his knee to get really
torqued out and
from there eddie bravo was
able to get underneath him like he said
he did the electric chair i think he did
it twice
uh nearly put him in a weird neck
cranking position by grabbing the
firearm at one point and
all of the control was based off of that
lockdown and because spoiler he wasn't
you know typically you to nerd out a
little bit typically the link that's
caught in the lockdown you want to bend
it your heel to your butt you kind of
want to
turn
away from them
and then bring it to your butt and then
you can turn back into them and extend
the leg and you legwork around their
legs
or if that doesn't work you can
incorporate your free leg and use that
and go kind of down
weave it in between their ankles and you
can straighten everything out and
release the lockdown he wasn't doing any
of that and it was very surprising and
that allowed eddie to get all the sweeps
and all of his setups for submissions
and then at the end he got in this
horrible crap calf crusher position
and if people aren't really familiar
with that
it gets used very legitimately at a very
high level sport jiu-jitsu especially
where like say uh i think vitor oliveira
recently who if you don't know who he is
is a gst fighter one of the biggest jiu
jitsu camps and this guy's a beast he's
been tearing through the american
circuit lately even though he's a
brazilian guy he went to the nogi worlds
last year and submitted
a black belt in tournament with that
same submission or you're in that calf
crusher just pulled the leg down and
it's uh
the only thing with the calf crusher is
that some people just do not tap to it
it's leg locks are a little bit tricky
like that
but when it's that it's just put on that
hard the way eddie had it and especially
with hoiler's knee being twisted to the
side like that it looked horrible it
looked fine uh
yeah i mean he was he was super deep he
must have rubber joints or something he
said he heard the knee pop at least six
times
and he kept twisting and he kept saying
you know are you okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know but you
heard what the man said he goes he's not
gonna tap the only way to top hoiler is
to choke him
the guy
i was really surprised because
i mean even the way that he was fighting
the electric chair sweep
when
you do the sweep with that lock down and
you torque their knee to the outside i
personally have torn someone's meniscus
with that because if they're stubborn
and they try to fight back by
straightening the knee and not
not trying to concede the sweep it can
go right on the knee and i've torn
someone's meniscus and i've seen other
people's masses torn from the same exact
position
so uh he wasn't fighting you know he
wasn't fighting that properly either he
was being stubborn with it the knee was
getting torqued really bad
and he was in a horrible position for
that calf crusher at the end like i said
um i was shocked to see him stand up at
the end and seemingly seemingly walk
around okay like i thought for sure that
it had just blown everything out of that
knee but
uh i don't know i guess we'll have to
hear reports from his camp afterwards
but uh
i mean he seemed okay
you know it's funny i did the podcast i
heard last night he goes that you know
for sure he's definitely got ice on it
today you know but there's another
school of thought for that john evan
you're a great jiu jitsu guy i mean
anybody i talk to
at vmac they all go [ __ ] john evan you
know you're very technical and stuff but
john evan you've just been doing just
over seven years
can you imagine what you're going to be
like at the 20-year mark
what also comes with that 20-year mark
is flexibility
it's it's uh you know you could take
your elbow to places i can't take mine
and lee can't take his you know you've
been doing the game for a long time you
know your limitations
you know i mean it's like the other
night i did something on stage i had to
stop to and when i got off both comics
were like bro you heckled you had you
handled that lady
[ __ ] perfectly it wasn't because i'm
better than you all it's because i've
been doing it for [ __ ] 20 years i'm
not better than you i just been doing it
for 20 years that's how i looked at that
that night that's just one of the things
that it means to do jiu jitsu you know
if you watch the one of the countdowns
to metamoris is he stretches he's a big
stretcher
you know we all stretch our hamstrings
and you know twist around but when do we
really get deep into our ankle and
switch it around and
when do we really do those deep
stretches which is what is needed for
jiu jitsu if you really think about it
you know
so sure no definitely and he said it he
goes you know it's 2014.
it's not just going to the jujitsu thing
anymore and doing hip escapes and
rolling there's so much more if you want
to get that much better
so uh you know the conditioning is is
great for you know all that stuff i mean
like i said you could pop my [ __ ]
finger but i know there's jujitsu guys
that you know they they [ __ ] they're
greater you can pull that finger back
for hours and nothing happens
no it's true there's definitely a level
of conditioning for
flexibility in joints and just
dean lister who actually competed in
this too also talks about it that
you've got like a
it's nearly like a conditioning for
submissions
you start to build a tolerance after a
while where
you know not for chokes because for
chokes if you get uh if you get choked
unconscious more than you know a handful
of times then it starts to your body
actually just like in boxing when boxers
start to get knocked out
more than a couple of times and their
chin knows
somehow that okay well i can stop all
this trauma and by just putting this
person to sleep then you do that and
then the guy starts passing out real
easy same thing with chokes
you know if you get choked out more than
a handful of times then you barely put
pressure on the neck and the guy will
pass out
but
other than that as far as like joints go
you can start to condition especially
for foot locks for straight ankle walks
you'll see a lot of the top guys that
have been put in a lot of horrible
uh straight ankle locks that would
separate the ankle from the leg or you
know just tear some of the ligaments
down in the foot and their feet are kind
of like flopping all over the place and
there's no expression on their face
they're fine there and the guy could be
in a really terrible deep belly down
foot lock and
the the guy's fine because their legs
have just been so battered over the
years that uh the feet are they're just
loose and they don't care so there's
definitely a level of conditioning that
comes with just training for a long long
time
it's uh and that
i'm really happy that may have played
the factor so no that definitely was you
know john i'm really happy for eddie and
i could tell in a way that
uh by the way you said that eddie did
great you know that you're happy in a
way also too i mean we're both fans of
jiu jitsu but i'm really uh eddie's one
of those guys that works hard
i mean do not get me wrong he's [ __ ]
crazy as cat [ __ ]
he's crazy as cat [ __ ] you know but
that's what makes eddie eddie and that's
what makes his jiu jitsu i mean who what
makes you wake up one morning and go you
know what
i think this is i think i got a way to
do this i think i got a better way than
the gracies and he's not saying that
he's never said that eddie has never
ever said that he's just said i have a
maybe a different way to look at this
that's what i mean to say i got a
different way to look at this and if you
do this you know what he was saying was
that you know if you're going to be
fighting an mma there's no geek
so why train with the ghee learn all
these different things and i'll tell you
uh
i'm in the same position in my career
he's a come-from-behind type of guy
and uh he took a lot of chances and uh
he's got a lot of [ __ ] talked about him
i mean people come up to me and say [ __ ]
sometimes
when i'm doing comedy after a comedy
show people come home and go how can you
hang you know let me tell you something
man that guy's done more for me as far
as uh his values and his way of thinking
than a lot of other people have done you
know
and uh i was just very proud of that
when i watched the the
thing the third time his fight i watched
it three times
i watched at the comedy show i watched
it on the plane and i watched it
yesterday the third time i was overcome
with tears because
i know what it's like to to have people
say [ __ ] and he's always he's always
been you know proven somebody wrong and
i give him props for that man that
he just wanted to change he just had a
belief and i'm sure you have beliefs
about jiu jitsu john evan you're very
good at what you do and i'm sure that
you have uh uh you've even taught it
you've even said to me listen this is
how they teach at most schools this is
how i teach it
you know with the one leg the the the
takedowns you've been teaching that you
review on tuesdays you know if you look
at the ufc and you look how they do
takedowns you're picking up your head
you're using your back you're doing a
deadlift and then you teach it this way
that it's just push him this way and let
his body do the work
you're following i mean there's there's
a million different ways to skin a cat
and
you know like you said motives too
like uh you know eddie might be crazy
you know quote unquote but i mean
honestly though it's like who's to say
eddie's any crazier than
hoiler who
lived
he ate slept and breathed jujitsu for
every year of his life you know like
that's not a normal life either
so it's just uh everyone's different
and eddie it was great to see him do
really well and i think a lot of people
discounted him because
he has grown a ton since him and hoiler
last
um
you know like
i think people forget that he was i
think he was either a brown belt or a
new black belt when they thought he was
a brown and
yeah and so much times past he's opened
up he he got the whole 10th planet thing
going and he's got
multiple schools and trains with a bunch
of top people and his game's completely
different and i mean even though he was
using a lot of
his half guard stuff in this that he's
known for uh you know he's progressed so
much and uh i think it was people that
were a little bit
you know
i mean on paper hoiler
is the better athlete and a better
competitor because you've done more
you've named the best fighter of the 90s
etc but
um
you know people in the know
i
think knew that it was a it was a much
bigger question mark about this match
because
you know who's training more and who
who's grown more and i think eddie has
definitely grown more because there was
more to improve upon with eddie's game
from when they last fought
and you know just what kind of shape
they're in and how they've updated their
games so
i definitely was not expecting a blowout
in this match at all and i think a lot
of people that were
higher level grapplers or at least
closer to the situation knew that it
could be a much closer match than what
people were giving any credit for so it
was great to see him come out and really
do
very well against such a top competitor
so i was very happy
hey hey john uh this is lee uh i have no
jiu jitsu background and i i i knew the
outcome of the fight before i watched it
and i thought it was intro because joey
brought up like he could watch this
every month
and i thought it was interesting that
four out of the six fights ended in a
draw and and in most american sports
there's a winner
so
is there a way like how can you how do
you explain to someone who doesn't know
jujitsu that a draw isn't a bad thing
because like it was when i looked at i
was like wow four out of six fights
ended with no one winning but then when
you see this fight you're like oh okay i
saw i see what happens like is there a
way there could be like some sort of
overtime where they do points or
something like that but it was just
it's uh it was it was surprising to me
that four out of the six fights in a big
professional fight no one won
yeah that's actually a
fantastic point that you bring up and
being someone that puts on their own
tournaments
myself like it's it's a really honestly
is the biggest issue with sport jiu
jitsu right now it's
what is the best tournament format
and i personally
there's pros and cons to the point
system and there's pros and cons to
submission only system i personally
don't believe that the current point
system that say the ibjf uses especially
their rule set
is the best
system
i really like submission only but then
you run into that whole time limit issue
uh metamora's tried to change it up from
the because this is now the third
metamorphosis i believe the first
metamoris
was
um
submission only and then i think
they did it just like this one where it
was a draw after a certain amount of
time
and then the second one
i don't believe there was no title yet
but the second one what they did is they
tried to do more like what you're saying
so they can have
the less draws
and what that resulted in was
a lot more confusion and a lot worse
matches so even though there was four
out of six matches went the distance
which
is not
ideal at all
these matches were much more exciting
because in the second one what they did
was they said okay 20 minutes
uh submission only and then at the end
of that match we'll have three judges
that will just say who's a winner
and absolutely with those four or six
matches that that were on this metamorse
card that did go the distance there was
pretty much a clear winner and loser in
each one of them but they can't when
they start to incorporate the
judging system then it becomes just the
same as point based because what
happened was a lot of the competitors
were fighting and they knew okay well
we're 10 minutes in this guy's too hard
to submit
and maybe i could make it work if i just
want balls out but i could also lose
you know like maybe i'd give up a
position or get too tired
and then if he starts dominating then
the judges will give the fight to him
and there's money on the line of course
too
so
people were just stalling more and
trying to get a decision out of it even
though there's no points
so it made the fights really a lot less
exciting and uh it was a shame but
that's the way it works if there's
any kind of a point system the fighters
will typically stall for that for those
points even if there's no points and
there's just judging
so it was really hard
for them to figure out a way
to
make less
drawings happen but
the only thing that they came up with
was 20 minutes just for a spectator
um
just for the reason of the spectators
being able to watch uh a predetermined
time limit match
uh instead of
having to schedule out your whole day
for
watching metamoris three because you
don't know how long the matches are
gonna go
and um trying to make a decisive winner
and make exciting fights so even though
there was the four fights that went to a
draw they were much more exciting fights
okay
i thought it was interesting one of the
fights that somebody won
somebody took the fight on 30 minutes
notice can you like what is that like
like he was just there probably like
like maybe as someone's part of a team
or something and like somebody had a
staff infection like how what is it like
like i don't think you've ever seen the
ufc fighter take a fight on 30 minutes
notice
no you you
typically would not see that that's
actually
pretty crazy
uh if you don't know who that was that
was actually someone who did fight in
the ufc he was on the ultimate fighter
it was kevin casey
kind of famous uh
hixon black belt
but he came in and stepped in for vinnie
magle hayes who had a horrible staph
infection they posted pictures on the
internet and it looked pretty nasty so
he had to step in on yeah like he said i
think it was 30 minutes notice which is
nuts
um
the only thing that that's good about
jiu-jitsu that's different from mma is
that if you mess up you're probably not
going to get your face punched in you're
not going to get any kind of you know
you're not going to get a bad concussion
or something like that
um of course you run the risk of being
submitted
and it may be
embarrassing or whatever but um and if
you tap early you're probably not going
to get hurt so that's one good thing
about jiu-jitsu you don't have to be
if it's not going to
endanger your career for taking a fight
on such short notice like it would maybe
an mma okay and then yeah
it was a really weird situation though
and um but i mean as long as you're
training even if you're maybe not in
perfect tournament shape if you're
training real hard all the time in the
gym and someone says hey do you want to
fight in this match maybe you're not
mentally prepared but you know
physically you're probably not too far
off so okay
and then what if they don't necessarily
peak like they do for mma
what are the weight classes because i
noticed uh hoyler and daddy had like a
10-pound weight difference is that
something they agree upon or or how what
is that because in in
mma it's like to the to the ounce
yeah in in mma it's really well i mean
if you want to look at a more
established sport look at boxing
where it's basically if you sneeze or
blow your nose then you're in a
different weight class so
there's a lot of little weight classes
because there's so many competitors and
as mma evolves there will be more weight
classes and we've seen it with ufc
already there was never i don't even
think
i mean in the beginning there was no
weight classes then there was just maybe
two i think like
uh
maybe up to 190 or something like that
and then 190 and over something like
that
and then now there's a bunch so and
they've incorporate they've started
incorporating even the smaller weight
classes like they have 145 which is
never one 135 and i think they have 125
now if i'm not mistaken
um so as the sport grows there will be
more weight classes and that changes
all the time same thing with the sport
jiu jitsu
um there's a bunch of weight classes
right now there might be more later on i
know they just added one more to the
female division for the ivjs rules
for this year so that's always a good
thing
um but yeah the the main thing you don't
want is you don't want like a huge
weight discrepancy so
this one it was just it's metamorph they
don't have to follow any kind of
athletic commission rules or anything i
don't think
so they just agreed upon a certain catch
weight or they could be different
weights and it wasn't too bad and part
of it
one of the interesting things was
some of the matches that they made
were
matches that you wouldn't
usually see in a tournament setting so
like a clark gracie versus hapa mendez
clark gracie's much bigger than hoffa
and hoffa is
super dominant in his weight division
there's only one or two people that
really give him issues in his weight
class
and we've seen those fights over and
over again because they're always
meeting in the finals for say the the
worlds in the idjs but hoffa unless he
fights the open class
would never fight clark gracie so for
them to make that match
it kind of makes more sense because
you know you get to see
maybe
clark gracie is probably like maybe a
top five in his weight division huff was
maybe like a top two uh top you know one
or two so he's right up there and
getting to see them both fight each
other when people say that maybe he's
the best pound for pound you you get to
see that uh put to the test so i thought
that was pretty interesting and you
wouldn't really get to see it elsewhere
so
but a big weight discrepancy there john
evan let me ask you something where's
your next backyard tournament
uh my next one
man i wanted to have it maybe in the
next week or so but the abu dhabi pro is
is coming up and some of the fighters
that i wanted to be in this one are
going to be competing in abu dhabi pro i
think that's like april 16th or
something so
i will be staying up all night watching
abu dhabi pro because they live stream
it and they do
they live streaming on their timetable
which is
pretty much the opposite of bars here in
america i think the live stream starts
at like 10 p.m or something so
uh after that though that will be a busy
weekend then maybe the weekend after
that
it'll be a it'll be a good one i think
we're gonna have a couple of
bigger name
grapplers and they're gonna fight for
hopefully bigger prize money this time
so should be a good one you are now the
official jiu jitsu guy for the church of
what's happening now
so you have the power to call in
whenever you want and discuss whatever
you want uh we love you here
uh that's john i i i as soon as i i
thought about you the whole weekend i'm
like i can't wait to get them on monday
morning so
i'm happy i called that i'm sorry you
had to get up early i know you like to
sleep till about 9 15 but maybe you'll
catch the nine o'clock and go bring this
today there you go see how inspiring um
yeah i know i i might do it i mean you
have to get in the car now and cut a
thousand [ __ ] off on the 101.
it's deep on a [ __ ] monday going into
hollywood but uh
i love that i love when you call in john
you know i'm a fan of yours how can they
find your breakdowns and everything
you're involved with with jiu jitsu
yeah so you can go to my youtube channel
that's where i do
all my main video updates that's just
youtube.com slash bjj breakdown
or you can go to my facebook page which
is facebook.com
bjj breakdown as well i also have
bjjbreakdown.com
but uh i'm redoing the site right now so
it's uh it may be
not quite up to date yet but what are
you going to do what are you going to
start your podcast john evan you need to
get out there i'd like to hear you more
you know
maybe
if jiu-jitsu gets more popular
especially with events like this that
are great and more accessible to the
average person
um
man i'm i'd love to start one as long as
there's a listener base out there that
would like to listen i'm telling you
you're knowledgeable so uh if you build
it they'll come trust me my brother
that's that's the goal hopefully with
all these tournaments and everything
people get more into it it's um some of
the most talented athletes out there are
in jiu-jitsu and it's a really hard
sport and it's a little bit discouraging
to see
some of the most amazing
technicians you've seen out there that
can barely scrape together to make ends
meet so hopefully
get some more money into the sport and
uh help these guys a little bit that's
what i'm trying to do brother thank you
very much for calling i'll call you
later on
oh definitely thank you guys so much for
having me
it's always a pleasure for you to call
men like i said you're the new
correspondent for the church of what's
happening now the jiu jitsu division so
you all you got to do is text me and say
joey i want to call up today i want to
talk about some of your family you're
good all right brother
awesome man thank you thank you john
evan have a great day
that was great you know yeah you know
hey listen man
kinda soul you know eddie gets tortured
eddie gets a lot of uh [ __ ] from people
and
a lot of people would quit don't ever
[ __ ] quit man like i said it only
hurts for as long as you let it you
[ __ ] move on and that's your gasoline
that's it i want to give some shout outs
to some bad [ __ ] today
my main man
don
sal zarullo sergio handahar
talking lair ernesto salazar john rallo
the teflon jew samuels my mannelia
samuels uh my man water boxer
anybody who came to the fort lauderdale
improv this weekend my man oscar nunez
oscar hernandez i love you [ __ ]
uh my man brock a lot of people came out
i met poor people i met this black lee
syed fan with a gold tooth who caught me
outside and was like
you but my main [ __ ] is lead the
[ __ ] flying jew where's the flying
jew at that's my [ __ ] he must have told
me that 15 [ __ ] times
man i'm happy you're here but man
i see that [ __ ] growing [ __ ] i
see them grow
i wish i would have got his name i would
have [ __ ] had him calling he was
hilarious cold tooth
the chick that wouldn't say nothing she
was like kind of scared that he might
beat her and [ __ ]
right there i'm like well if you're
listening email me at flyingdo radio
gmail
i want to give a shout out to my [ __ ]
sponsors hulu plus as usual [ __ ]
making it happen 7.99 a month
watch all shows whenever the [ __ ] you
want on whatever device you want your
phone
your tablet your
whatever your [ __ ] hand i don't give
a [ __ ] if you stick a plug in your ear
and watch it on your [ __ ] hand that's
how hulu plus world goes go to
huluplus.com
or go to joeydears.net go to
huluplus.com box and press in joey boom
get two weeks for free if you just go to
hulu.com you get who gots for free you
get one week i'm giving you a deuce plus
7.99 a month that's 96 a year for
[ __ ] entertainment 100 a year out of
the [ __ ] whatever money you make i'm
not asking you for much go to
huluplus.com and uh press joey and get
your [ __ ] party
started [ __ ] that's how we roll
honor.com i can't thank you enough i
can't thank you for what you've done for
me uh your products you know whenever i
contact you you send me my alpha brain
you know i just finished the one alpha
brain cycle i'm gonna start another one
about three weeks the shroom tech i'll
be taking it tonight for jiu jitsu i
mean i believe in this [ __ ] folks and
it's helped me uh the shroom tech sport
has helped me with my endurance that's
the one that i'm really if if all their
products are as good as shroom tech
sport then we got something [ __ ]
special here they have the digestive the
enzymes they've got the [ __ ] hem
force protein which is sensational we
were talking about last night that on
the eddie broadway podcast go to
honor.com go to joeydears.net on the on
and press what church church c-h-u-r-c-h
you have that booyah
also to my [ __ ] great friends at
dollar [ __ ] shave club making
it happen again i got home today there
was a thing of [ __ ] razors right
there it's not even the [ __ ] first
they're better than welfare you
understand better than [ __ ] welfare
it gets to your house on it also has the
program you can stay on it you get 20
off they mail everything to your house
the first of the month dollar shave club
does that a nice razor some [ __ ] four
blades let's say you want to wipe your
[ __ ] they go one white charlie's oh
yeah coco by the shave dollar shave club
don't [ __ ] around go to dollar shave box
and press church church when you go to
joey dears.net also my brothers are
escape pod.tank i love jeremy
tank escape pod tank what'd i say escape
podtank.com yeah you added a dot i know
i'm sorry
i'll drink some [ __ ] water here
jeremy always answer the 1-800 go to
their web page escape podtank.com go to
the 1-800 number call if you have any
questions i'll tell you what they're a
leader in the industry they have the
industrial ones they have the ones for
your [ __ ] house they have the ones
for your backyard you could jump in
there scrub your nuts close the hatch
whatever the [ __ ] you want to do you
could do with escape pod tank.com go
over there tell them we sent you get 250
off if you live somewhere they'll
deliver it listen they're nice [ __ ]
guys this is what you want to do
business with not only that that i'm
going to save you two grand on a [ __ ]
tank there you have it plus the 250 and
buy a t-shirt that's what the [ __ ] do
all right and that's it we got a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive it's
gonna be 60 degrees i'm tired today oh
yeah
i think i'm gonna go to kettlebell class
tonight
or just go to jiu jitsu tonight because
it's a marcel madness at vmac tonight
for the first half hour he makes you do
jumping jacks and [ __ ]
burpees and [ __ ] push-ups i can't do
burpees
i can't do the hill climb as i try them
you know but i'm working every day man
i'm trying to [ __ ] do this every day
this weekend i ran two days
i wrote the book inside or outside
because outside my house inside inside
yeah it wasn't that bad it wasn't that
it was cloudy it wasn't sunny at all i
got oh wow it was cloudy all [ __ ]
three days i uh rode the bike for the
first time because my my knee was
bothering me oh [ __ ] so i wanted to
really give it some mobility so i rode
the bike both days for 20 minutes then i
uh got on the treadmill and did the
dolce dive for 40 minutes so it's a 60
minute of cardio you know i burned some
calories my shirts were [ __ ] sweaty
as [ __ ] they smelt
but uh you know you run what the dolce
thing is you walk the first five minutes
on
uh like 3.5
and then after that every two minutes
you jog or you sprint for 30 seconds and
then you walk two minutes so it's not
bad you can cover you put a good you put
an album on on your ipod just put the
album on because it's gonna take you 30
minutes and you just put the you walk
for the first five then you [ __ ] around
with it sometimes i put it all the way
up to like 6.5 and i only sprint for 15
seconds but then i'll rest for a minute
and 45 seconds so you can play around
with it you know i do it for like jiu
jitsu to get out of uh you know you're
on the bottom and you want to [ __ ]
hip escape and then put him back in your
guard so that's all i'm doing with that
little running thing but it was mike
dolce who invented it i didn't invent it
i just modified it a little bit like
eddie bravo modified jiu jitsu so i did
that so today
i was to take sunday and go back at it
today but i'm just physically tired i
think i'm going to go back and have
breakfast with the family and maybe do
that and maybe just
[ __ ] around and write you know do all
that stuff what do you got planned out
talk like you got a podcast
uh the red sox coming what time the red
sox opening days at noon oh [ __ ] i was
gonna go down to the boxing barn the
[ __ ] gummy bear okay let's eat the
[ __ ] i was gonna go to the boston bar in
santa monica but
yeah
let's take it out we gotta we got a
[ __ ] green hole in it leaving like
monday
the march 30th that's how we're starting
this [ __ ] yeah line up bush the
sound of winter eddie played it last
night now it's been on my mind all
[ __ ] morning
it's gonna be interesting flying to your
radio on a podcast i'm not edible
delicious today
they do a good job with these [ __ ]
green ones i'll tell you that much
only that they [ __ ] you up too
um
yeah
um
just like mommy used to yeah i don't
know how
i like that so much more than anything
chocolate based i can't do that but
that's that's yummy you don't like the
chocolate basically
this week we're doing a special podcast
wednesday at one o'clock
i got a special guest for you
[ __ ] i just needed to confirm
and that's it we got a great week coming
next week i'm at the this thursday i'm
at the tempe improv but next week i'm in
grand [ __ ] rapids michigan
[ __ ] break out the dirty white women
with dirty feet i love it i love
michigan i love tempe i can't wait to
see you [ __ ] this weekend
besides that that's it yeah if you if
you have a second go to lisa.com
everything i do is there i appreciate it
okay no and also for you [ __ ]
asking you ready the coffee cups are in
the t-shirts are in all i'm waiting on
is the ghee patches and after that the
store will be open my wife is gonna open
the store this week for pre-order like
lee did with his t-shirts we'll be
sending them out next week we got short
sleeve uh church of what's happening now
t-shirts and long sleeve church what's
happening in our t-shirts that i've been
selling on the road when the sleeve says
the flying jew you know what i'm saying
you got a [ __ ] a [ __ ] with balls and a
crucifix on your [ __ ] shirt what else
do you need if that don't get you
started
nothing's gonna get you started i love
you [ __ ] from the church what's
happening now have a great day i want to
thank all my sponsors again huluplus.com
on it escape.tank.com
and dollar shave club i love you guys
have a great [ __ ] day have a great
monday remember [ __ ] them all up the ass
don't give a [ __ ] what they got to say
you're the captain kirk or you're
enterprise you're the [ __ ] that
goes to shop right or or panty pride or
[ __ ] albertsons and pays for your own
groceries and if you have something to
say time to suck your dick and call you
shorty you were born in 1940 you ain't
you're going to be the best [ __ ]
you could be [ __ ] the national anthem
today it is your own personal anthem
this is the personal anthem you're
playing your [ __ ] hat every morning
when you wake up today they're going to
suck my all these people with their
positive reaffirmings i am who i am you
know i'm confident go [ __ ] yourself
you're a bad [ __ ] you gotta say
that to yourself in the morning with one
eye shut so it [ __ ] into your [ __ ]
brain like popeye with one [ __ ] eye
look at yourself and go i'm a bad
[ __ ] nobody's gonna [ __ ] with me
today somebody's gonna suck my dick
today somebody's gonna [ __ ] pay me
today and today i'm gonna be a lot
better than i was [ __ ] yesterday the
church or what's happening now i love
you [ __ ] stay black go out
there mug somebody hit it leave you bad
[ __ ] now that the show is over
don't forget to sign up for your free
trial please
stop this [ __ ] jeff [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] what you've been doing
thousands of hit shows anytime anywhere
on your tv pc smartphone or tablet
support this podcast and get an extended
free trial of hulu plus when you go to
huluplus.com joey or go to joeydiaz.net
and click on the hulu plus banner and
don't forget to sign up for
dollarshaveclub.com get high quality
razors sent to your door a month for
fraction of what you pay at retail go to
dollar shave club dot com forward slash
church or go to joey's